let's get the latest on vaccine
therapies and the rest of the
chronovirus developments joining us
tonight from the white house white house
response coordinator
dr deborah burks uh dr burks thanks for
being here thank you
we have a lot of questions for you a lot
from viewers
but right now there are a lot of people
afraid they are uncertain
they are facing a school year many
parents wondering what's going to happen
tonight where is this virus in your mind
we just heard the president
but from you the medical expert where is
it
so this particular pandemic that we're
experiencing across the south the
southeast and into the southwest
and west is very different than what we
experienced in march and april
what do i mean by that this epidemic
all appeared across the south and the
west
after june 10th simultaneously
previously in the march april time frame
first we had the new york metro
following washington state and then a
series of metros that went down
in a period of time often two or three
weeks apart
this time we saw a wide virus spread
across counties across rural areas
across small metros and big metros
all the way across the south southwest
and west almost simultaneously
so this was an event that we think can
be traced to
memorial day and opening up and people
traveling again and being on vacations
and we're really tracking this because
where it hasn't happened
yet is our midwest and our northeast
that was so hard hit
in march and april and so we're watching
that very carefully what's the top stat
that you're following
you what are you looking at day to day
the top
statistic that you're looking for so we
send a report
every week on mondays to every single
governor it's about 10 pages per
state it really goes into detail what we
think is the most sensitive indicator
is what we call test positivity and it
only has to go up a tiny bit
so let's say you had three percent test
positive and then the next week you have
3.3 percent
that is when to start really watching we
think that's the earliest indicator
that's why we show that at county level
at metro level at small cities and large
metro areas as well as a state level
so that every governor and every mayor
and every health commissioner
can really understand what we're seeing
in their state and so that we can really
provide recommendations to the states on
how best to control this fire
speaking of testing the president
mentioned it but you're at over
50 million 343 000 tests
positive tests reported about 4 653 000
the percentage
of positive tests 9 here's the question
though that we're getting a lot
and that is the time it takes to get
the tests and the results from the test
if it takes one two
three even four days what's the purpose
of the test
from a medical contact tracing
possibility so you're absolutely right
the turnaround times particularly across
the south
are too long we've been working at state
by state levels to
when the president talked about a change
in strategy really increasing
our strategy we course have a testing
strategy but really to address these
turnaround times
will be absolutely critical and then the
most hardest hit
states they are having the longest
turnaround times how did this happen
well if you look right now and you've
had it on just before
we have three states that are equivalent
to what the worst conditions were
as far as number of tests required was
new york and we have three states
approaching those case numbers so now we
need three times really
the number of tests that we had before
and so we're really working
to increase pooling we know that can
dramatically increase our throughput
really we need the northeast and the
midwest that have those very low test
positive rates to move to pooling
so that those tests can be moved to the
south the southwest and the west
just like early on we shifted a lot of
testing into the northeast we need the
northeast now to help us
by doing pooling they have test
positivities often
under three percent we think they're in
the perfect situation to combine three
or four
different tests into one tube to run it
and that increases our capacity by
4x and so this is what we're really
asking each of the states to work on to
do
we're asking the platforms the roche and
labcorp
and quest and other large commercial
labs to really look at pooling in the
midwest
and the northeast so that we can make
tech more tests available
to the south and the south but does it
fail fair to say that that is a national
failure testing here here back in march
13th here's what we were saying back
then you were saying from
from the briefings back then
clients and patients and people of
interest can go
fill out a screening questionnaire they
would move down this
and be told where the drive-through
options would be for them
to receive this test the labs will then
move to the high throughput
automated machines to be able to provide
results
in 24 to 36 hours that just did not
materialize
how come so that did materialize all
through may and the first part of june
and almost to the end of june we had
turn around times in less than 24 hours
to 48 hours when you include the fact
that we had to ship the samples
so the drive-throughs were working the
pharmacies and
we had multiple sites across the united
states
we had point of care available
throughout the united states
but when you have this level of outbreak
and that's why i wanted to start that
way
we have almost 70 percent of every
parish in louisiana with a test
positivity above 10 percent
we have almost 65 percent of all the
counties in alabama mississippi i was
just
in the field at all of these nine states
with these recent outbreaks to really
understand what they are facing
this is a very different epidemic than
we had in march and april and it will
require
additional tests and so this surge in
this degree of case is so widespread
compared to previously does have to be
addressed i think that's what the
president is talking about when he
talked about yesterday
increasing our tests and having a
strategy that surges tests
into the area so we can really decrease
those turnaround times
we know how important those are we know
how important it is for everybody to
know
immediately whether they're positive or
not so they can be isolated and prevent
further transmission dr burks we have
some specific tweets and facebook posts
from viewers if you just have a couple
more minutes
on the other side of the break we could
ask those to you perfect
okay we'll see in a little bit
[Music]
we're back with dr debra burks about the
latest on the coronavirus thanks for
sticking around
the president just said this he was
asked about schools reopening
and about kids and infection rates
here's what he said
we understand that the children who go
to school and
go back to home they're with some live
with their grandparents there's there's
a real risk would you understand if
somebody they do say
that they don't transmit very easily and
a lot of people are saying they don't
transmit and we're looking at that we're
studying john very hard
that particular subject that they don't
bring it home with them now they don't
catch it easily they don't bring it home
easily and if they do catch it they get
better fast we're looking at that fact
that is a factor and we're looking at
that very strongly we'll be reporting
about that over the next week
so is that right is that what you're
looking at i mean what do you know about
kids and transmitting or kids and
getting it
so that's a really key question the best
study out so far is a study from south
korea that looked at children and looked
at children under 10 and children over
10.
i think what we need to do and what
we're really trying to do right now
is to really look at what the antibody
levels are already in children under 18.
so we're launching a very large
zero survey across all age groups to
really understand where has this virus
been
who has is infected who is infectable
and who is transmitting the virus and so
i think i think there's still
open questions there and that's why the
president concluded with
we're studying this very hard i think
it's a very important question that we
have to understand
do children under 10 transmit the virus
less
that's what the south korea study
suggests but i think it really needs to
be confirmed here
i think that's the kind of questions
that have to be critically answered
and i think the multi-generational
household question is critically
important i come from one of those
multi-generational households i have a
96 year old and a 91 year old mother and
father that i'm always worried about and
protecting
so i don't even see them so i understand
but i guess
parents want their kids to be studying
in school but this is a crucial question
we're almost coming to august these
schools are making decisions
about what they're going to do this
seems to be kind of a linchpin as to
whether
they're going to open or do distance
learning i mean what is your
recommendation
i think there's three pieces and i think
the cdc has put this out
quite well and i think the president
will talk about schools again
sometime this week and the cdc will put
out additional recommendations
i think it's a very important point
children that have pre-existing
conditions that we know are susceptible
to the virus
they probably should not be in an
in-school situation where there's active
virus circulating teachers
that have what we call pre-existing
conditions that put them at a higher
risk for more severe disease
they have to be accommodated and then
the majority of the children
what is their risk we know from data
today that children do quite
well with the virus so if we protect the
teachers we have teachers in the
classroom that are protected
through innovation some people are
putting up plastic shields
of course many schools are having
children and teachers in mass
we know all these things work and i
think it really requires school
districts
to plan and be flexible and put that the
child at the center to decide
what is better for the children of
america and what's best
to protect the children and their
household at home and everybody's going
to have to work through those very
specific issues
okay a couple of viewer questions real
quick these two are related benji for dr
burks we are hearing reports that
antibodies are not lasting
long post infection how does that change
the game for vaccine development are
there statistics on re-infection same
question josie says
if you've tested positive whether full
on symptoms or asymptomatic
can you be reinfected do we know the
answer to that question
now so great immunologic questions
and i trained in clinical immunology so
this is very an important question
so the first question about persistence
of antibodies
even when we're vaccinated our
antibodies
wane they decrease over time that's what
antibodies are supposed to do
but there's another part of the immune
system what we call the memory part of
the immune system
and the cellular arm of the immune
system so when you ever
encounter that virus again those
antibodies and that immune
response immediately surge so what used
to take you maybe
10 to 14 days to develop now appears
in 24 to 48 hours allows you to re-clear
that virus and so
that's what happens with other viruses
and other infectious diseases i think
the question
about can you be reinfected you know we
have a lot of cases out there and we
have a lot of cases now over the last
six months and we don't see this high
level of reinfection what assures me
is we know that people the majority of
people around the world once they're
infected
they amount to immune response both what
we call the antibody response and the
cellular response
and they clear the virus that is the
road map for vaccine development that's
the road map for monoclonal antibodies
for therapeutics
and i think that's what's so encouraging
about this virus and our ability to
clear it
two more things one is the washington or
the new york times had this massive
piece
in which um they have this this sentence
inside the white house dr burks was the
chief evangelist
for the idea that the threat from the
virus was fading did you read that piece
and what'd you make of it
so i i'm a data person so i went back to
that very specific day
i um report out the data every single
day so i went back to that day and i
looked at my report
and my report started out with we are
seeing improvements
in new york and new jersey but we're
seeing increasing concerns and we're not
at peak in boston or chicago
we have new concerns in houston and we
have new
hot spots developing in washington dc
and across the south
so to me that's a very balanced report
that's what epidemiologists and data
people do they just put the data
out there as it exists i was surprised
by the piece because most people will
tell you
that i air on the other side that i am
too forceful and too direct often about
the data and what it's showing
um and i've never actually been called
an optimist in that way before
so well last thing another report in a
washington post piece said berks and
others were frustrated with the cdc's
antiquated system
for tracking virus data which they
worried was inflating some statistics
such as mortality rate and case count
by as much as 25 percent there's nothing
from the cdc that i can trust
burke said according to two people is
that true
and where do you think the cdc data is
today so those are two pieces put
together
so what is cdc extraordinary about and
what are we using every single day
their surveillance data their
epidemiologic data
their laboratory data and their
integration of all of that data and the
analysts that are down there as
epidemiologists and analysts that were
provide those reports i rely on those
that data is all superb
that comment was about daily
hospitalization data when we were first
trying to put out rendez-severe
i it's important to me that there's
extraordinary equity
in how we distribute medication when
it's needed for
really a very specific patient and so we
were
having a really passionate and
compassionate discussion
about what's best for patients and we
were talking about the hospital data and
the importance of
daily complete reporting and that's what
we were talking about is the hospital
data specifically
the epidemiology data the surveillance
data the influenza-like illness
surveillance data the emergency room
syndromic management
surveillance all terrific critical
and it's not just the data it's the
people they bring to the table to
analyze it
dr burks we kept you too long please
tell the white house we apologize but we
appreciate your time and you're welcome
back anytime
because our viewers have a lot of
questions as you can imagine thank you